President Trump
has tweeted a lot
of ridiculous things recently,
but perhaps the most ridiculous
was this tweet from Thursday...
Here to talk about it is one
of our writers, Amber Ruffin.
-Hi, Seth.
-Hi, Amber.
What do you think
about Trump saying
he's done more for women
than any American president
in history?
-I think he's correct.
-You don't disagree
with that statement?
-Why should I?
It's true.
[ Upbeat jazz plays ]
-It is?
-It is.
-How is that possible?
What has he done?
-What has Trump done for women?
Well...
♪♪
He did this...
He did that...
♪♪
He did this and this and this...
Don't you forget about that...
♪♪
-But those are all bad things.
-He didn't say he's done
good things for women.
He just no president
has done more, and he's right.
No president has done more
for women.
To make our lives worse!
♪♪
He's done this...
He's done that...
♪♪
He said this and this
and this...
Don't you forget about that...
♪♪
-Wow.
That is a lot.
-It sure is.
-Do you have more?
-Seth, I can do this forever!
♪♪
He also did this and this
and this and this
and this.
[ Clapping ]
Can you believe he did
this and this
and this and this...?
And don't you ever forget
he did this...
♪♪
-♪ And ♪
♪ Thi-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i... ♪
♪ ...i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i... ♪
♪ ...ooh-ee ooh-ee... ♪
♪ ooh-ee-ee-i-i-i-s... ♪
♪♪
-Wow.
That's...more than a lot.
-Mm-hmm.
-So, are you done?
-Mnh-mnh.
-Okay.
♪♪
-He also did this...
He did this...
Can you believe he did this...?
Most of all, he did this...
♪♪
He did that?
♪ That's what he did ♪
-Thanks, Amber.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."